herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren jetzt mal ehrlich wo fühlen sie
sich den zu hause erreichen dafür nicht
ihre liebsten und ein dach über dem kopf
wozu also brauchen wir kunstvolle teure
architektur darüber spreche ich jetzt
mit dem weltbekannten basler architekten
jacques herzog herzlich willkommen
ja wo fühlen sie sich denn zu hause
herzog
ich fühle mich zu hause zu hause das
heißt ganz banal
dort wo ich wohne wir wollen nicht dort
wo ich reise
das ist glaube ich wichtig wenn sie mich
fragen zu hause es gibt ja menschen die
fühlt sich wohl wenn sie immer unterwegs
sind und ich habe da ein extrem
statisches bedürfnis vielleicht genau
als reaktion auf die vielen reisen die
wir seit vielen jahren jetzt machen
müssen und wie leben sie zu hause war
sowie wohnen sie ich wohne in einem haus
das wie früher baut herzog de meuron
bereich als social housing also nicht in
einem einfamilienhaus und mitten in der
stadt in einem haus in einem hinterhof
man ziemlich versteckt und das war alles
nicht geplant da wo wir sind da
geblieben und weil es wir weil wir das
sehr wohl sind meine familie und ich und
das gehört alles zu diesem zuhause dass
es eben allen gefällt die mich umgeben
die mir nahe sind auch die freunde da
bin ich auch eigentlich eher altmodisch
es ist wichtig dass das wohnen zu hause
mit diesen mit der nähe zu den freunden
verbunden ist
also bei mir spüre ich dass ich für mich
da zu hause wo ich mich einerseits
verwurzelt fühlen wo ich soziale
kontakte habe wo ich mich aber auch in
der umgebung in die wieder erkennen weil
ich vieles irgendwie vieles gewohnt ist
versuchen sie dieses dieses gefühl sich
wie das ok zu erkennen in der umgebung
auch mit ihrer architektur umzusetzen
das ist ja eine wechsel wäre
wenn ein mensch irgendwo aufwächst dann
prägt ihn das und es gibt menschen die
wollen da ausbrechen wollen ganz was
anderes
andere städte andere länder anderes
kommt anderer kontinent oder andere tier
wieder genau das immer wieder suchen
dieses patrick und sicher ist es so dass
die frage die sich stellt gar nicht auf
das psychologische institut hin dass uns
sehr wichtig ist diese psychologische
seite
weil wenn man jetzt nicht vom einzelnen
menschen ausgeht sondern von einer stadt
irgendeine stadt jede stadt ist es doch
so dass wenn man sie anschaut ganz
nüchtern war nimmt diese stadt jede
stadt hier sehr viel interessantes
erzählt über ihre geschichte aber auch
wie sie den menschen prägt durch die
natur durch die 8er gebäude der hohen
niedrige gut unterhalten schlecht
unterhalten
das sind an sich schon mal sehr
interessante informationen städte
anzuschauen und landschaften anzuschauen
und zu sehen wie was sagen dir diese
städte die haben es ist ja nicht eine
sprache aber es ist eine körperhaltung
in agenturen städten die einschüchternd
ist oder die vertraulich wird oder die
intim wirkt oder die einschüchternde ist
also durch den maßstab oder durch die
proportionen
das wiederum kommt dann in eine
politische frage weil es gibt
architektouren die natürlich aus
politischen gründen gemacht wurden und
menschen einzuschüchtern sozialrealismus
sowjetunion ohne dass in ostdeutschland
andere wiederum gewachsene orte von
bewohnern oder von
ethnische gruppen kontrolliert und
bebaute ort die wiederum sehr stark mit
dem im leben der menschen durch das
leben der menschen geprägt ist nicht
doch eine politische macht geprägt ist
aber ein ganz großes spektrum das da
aber andererseits nicht nur geprägt ist
sondern auch punkt also wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe prägt architektur auch
ein stück weit unsere identität
ja es ist ja interessant dass wenn dann
kinder schon ganz früh fragt wie ist
zeichne mir ein haus das noch heute
kinder das haus mit einem ziegeldach
zeichnen sogar behaupte ich wenn sie in
einer umgebung aufgewachsen sind wo das
gar nicht
prägend ist es gibt das muster in den
menschen und die sind ganz wichtig für
den architekten auch was die bewusst
oder intuitiv kennt oder was sie gar
nicht beachtet das hat dann häufig damit
zu tun wie gut die architektur ist im
sinne von ist sie von den menschen
akzeptiert und fühlen sich die menschen
wohl in diesen aspekten das hat mit
dieser prägung sehr stark zu tun
die höhle wir haben hier auch steinwände
17 zwar nicht zu hören aber nicht
irgendeinen grund hat es ja weshalb wir
hier auch diese wende so gemacht habe
dass er auch psychologisch nicht
uninteressant fühlen sie sich wohl hier
im studio die zuhörerinnen und zuschauer
sehen natürlich nicht dass das keine
echten steine sind deshalb nicht wert
wenn ich sagen würde ich fühle mich
nicht wohl aber es ist ein versuch ja
mit diesen steinen eine atmosphäre zu
schaffen die etwas permanent das etwas
festes suggeriert oder und das ist
durchaus eine psychologische architektur
man will mit stein hat eine ganz andere
ausstrahlung als holz oder beton
blech oder und aldi material sind
interessant aber sie sind eben nicht
unschuldig denn sie haben eine eine
wirkung auf den menschen die wir diese
wirkung waren wir sprechen über dieses
nicht unschuldige über diesen
ausstrahlung haben sie gesagt bedeutungs
überschuss vielleicht charakter ausdruck
es gibt ganz viele worte dafür
und wenn man ihre gebäude anschaut dann
sieht man auch wie vielfältig dieser
charakter dieser identität von gebäuden
sein kann und wir schauen uns dazu ein
paar bilder an
[Musik]
ja alle diese gebäude haben so etwas wie
ein charakter oder eine identität fast
schon wie ein mensch manche sind
verspielt manche ernst lieblich warum
können wir gebäude so beschreiben wie
wir menschen beschreiben
der komplizierte frage weil eine ganze
geschichte dahinter ist es gibt ja bei
vitruv also 16 jahrhundert traktate aber
schon also im hof gab es früher schon
traktate oder einem mittelalter neue
wiederum traktate die auf diesen artikel
neben von metros und so weiter aufbauten
welche genau diese frage ins zentrum
stellen also eine säule zum beispiel die
eine art abbild von menschen ist jeder
kennt von griechenland diese weiblichen
figuren die asäulen dastehen
und tatsächlich hatte eine säule etwas
das die sind den blick nimmt er so dass
die seile war und sie hat spricht in wie
zu dir wie eine figur fast das ist
eigentlich was der direkteste vergleich
auch häufig so gemeint früher das eine
säule eine art nicht ebenbild aber ein
yard abbild von menschen ist es gibt es
ist ja auch allen bekannt diese
proportions lehrern zuletzt von gekommen
ist welche die menschliche und masse
also fing ellbogen fuß das sind ja alles
maße direkt von menschen kommen
also es ist klar dass architektur für
den menschen gemacht ist und vom
menschen gemacht ist das heißt es gibt
dieses dieses wechselspiel und das soll
es ja auch geben
architekten vergessen dass häufig und
das gibt dann häufig seien die skos
infrastruktur überrascht act uhr aus
architektur als architektur das finde
ich persönlich langweilig finde
architektur interessant in dieser
wechselwirkung zum menschen und zur
gesellschaft
also wie wehrt sich architektur im
öffentlichen raum
nur so wird sie überleben wenn sie diese
maxime oder diesen dieses bedürfnis
erfüllen kann
das zeigt auch weshalb alte gebäude
templiner kennen zum beispiel japan die
ganz fragil gebaut sind weshalb es die
heute noch gibt weil rein von der
materiellen überlebensfähigkeit während
die ja ganz weit unten vergleich
verglichen mit 4 oder stein gebaut sind
aber das überleben weil weil sie etwas
haben dass die menschen anzieht
menschenleben ist das ist wichtig die
menschen sollen architektur lieben oder
zumindest sich wohl fühlen und ist ohne
dass es ihnen sage ich mal bewusst ist
ohne dass diese es verbal ausdrücken
man spürt es ob sie menschen sich
irgendwo wohl fühlen oder nicht länger
und vielleicht liegt das daran dass
diese gebäude etwas verkörpern
vielleicht ein lebens ideal verkörpern
und der schweizerisch englische
philosoph alain de botton hat ein buch
geschrieben glück und architektur und
darin schreibt er die dinge die wir
schön finden sind spielarten der
menschen die wir lieben genau war es
eben diese charaktereigenschaften
irgendwie symbolisch verkehrt wenn sie
dem zustimmen ist jetzt dass die frage
nach schönheit oder ist dass die franke
ist die frage wie schönheit oder das
ästhetische empfinden mit unseren lebens
ideal mit ethik zusammenhängt dass nur
ein bisschen zu weit gegriffen ich finde
es gibt wie das eine was ich vorhin
sagte dass der mensch in architektur
sich wohlfühlen soll das ist wie ein
raum oder ein gefäß ich benutze wie das
beispiel von eingeborenen architektur
häufig diese trulli diese und formen das
sind ja wie abgefasst vom vom
alltäglichen leben von menschen das sind
wahrscheinlich die besten architektouren
weil dies sind wird
unmittelbar kommen die aus dem
gebrauchen dass der aus den ritualen im
alltag dieser völker heute ist das
natürlich viel distanziert heute macht
die architektur die als der architekt
die architektur und da stellt sich diese
frage vielmehr aus dieser distanz sie
aber es ist immer schön oder was ist
richtig für den menschen
für uns war schönheit immer ein
politischer begriff eine art
liebeserklärung im sinne dass die us
tour von menschen wahrgenommen wird
das so wie sich auch fragt weshalb man
gebäude gefällt und dass er von dieser
schönheit falls es fast als es um findet
auch herausgefordert wird ich denke
schönheit dazu damit zu tun dass du aus
betrachtet ob es ein bild ist oder ein
baum oder ein stück architektur
provoziert wirst dich selbst
wahrzunehmen also dich selbst irgendwie
zu erkennen als wahrnehmen und das tönt
jetzt ein bisschen hochgestochen aber
das ist das politische
das meint ja auch noch kurs in seiner
ästhetik begriff dass schönheit etwas
politisches ist weil es den menschen
ernst nimmt weil es den menschen dazu
auffordert das war auch zu nehmen diesen
wahrnehmungs prozess als etwas als etwas
energiereiches das etwas motivierendes
als etwas inspirierendes ja dass da ein
prozess und steht der den menschen etwas
gibt und dass ihn eben stark macht wenn
du ein bild erkennst und die du liebst
etwas durch die nz was in einem museum
oder ein gebäude ist diese warnung
prozess das ist dann ein eigener prozess
du erkennst es also das so und nicht
anders
nicht weil jemand dir gesagt das schauen
wir das ist ein schönes haus ist alles
aus unter die bilder anzuschauen weil
sie so teuer sind und du hast
erkannt dass das eine tolle arbeit ist
als mensch siehst du das und das ist
eine eigene wahrnehmung energie das ist
für mich der interessanteste begriff von
schönheit weil er damit zu tun hat weil
er mit dem einzelnen die wied und zu tun
hat deshalb kann ich auch nicht objektiv
sagen
ab 6 uhr ist schön wenn sie so und so
ist es gibt keine objektivität es gibt
eine art inter subjektivität wenn viele
menschen jetzt zum beispiel die
elbphilharmonie die gezeigt oder die
finden
fast alle toll und ich kann nicht
objektiv sagen ich frage das
interessiert mich auch nicht ehrlich
gesagt weshalb jetzt das schön es ist
interessant ist dass menschen viele
menschen jetzt plötzlich das sehr schön
finden weil sie darin sich selbst
irgendwie als sich selbst etwas noch
immer kennen aber dann ist das doch der
grund weil sie sagen sie interessiert
sie nicht warum die das schön finden
leider hat sie sich selbst wieder
erkennen und weil es etwas anstößt
vielleicht diesen prozess den sie den
sie auch gleich sagt nur ich kann nicht
objektiv ich kann das nicht wie
objektivieren
wenn du in einer jury bist und sagst wir
machen jetzt einen wettbewerb oder wir
fahren welches gebäude ist da ein
schönes gebäude
es gibt vielleicht ein konsens in der
jury das ist ein art inter subjektiver
konzern viele finden das schön es ist
aber nicht objektiv so dass sonst wir
servieren ein rezeptbuch ich hätte das
ja sonst fahrzeugen und du versuchst
dass architekt das natürlich zu
erreichen in diesem moment wo menschen
etwas schön finden etwas lieben etwas
akzeptieren vielleicht sollte man das
auf einer ebene ein bisschen ruth
bekochen
die menschen gehen gerne hin
gerade bei öffentlichen gebäuden wir
machen mittlerweile viel mehr
öffentliche gebäude in unsere jüngeren
karriere und logischerweise wollte
niemand von uns ein theater oder ein
konzerthaus und jetzt sind häufig diese
art von projekten geben
ich kann sind und deshalb ist diese
frage viele relevant weil es eine viel
größere öffentlichkeit betrifft mich
würde interessieren braucht architektur
ihrer ansicht nach eine idee ein konzept
dahinter oder reicht es wenn sie von den
menschen angenommen wird wenn dieser
stimmigen eindruck entsteht
das geht natürlich nur wenn ein konzept
also eine konzeptuelle energie dahinter
ist oder ein konzeptueller aufbau und so
wie wir arbeiten angefangen mit pierre
und meeres als quasi zwei gruppe und
dann später mit angestellt haben wir
immer diese konzeptuelle
herangehensweise gefördert weil wenn du
alleine bist bestimmst du alles mit
einer genialen haben oder - also bei uns
war das eben nur ein dialog zwischen
pierre und mir und jetzt heute zwischen
uns und einzelnen partnern und deshalb
ist die konzeptuelle ebene sehr wichtig
weil du musst das wir haben sprachliche
begriffliche ebene verständlich machen
das heißt es ist dann nicht objektiv
aber es ist ein dialog
du musst das überzeugen ein überzeugend
darstellen und konzipieren damit andere
im team daran teilnehmen können diesen
dialog das ist auch eine art kritik eine
ständige kritik an diesem prozess des
entwerfens und es wäre das gebäude
ich möchte mit ihnen drei gebäude
anschauen und bitte sie ganz kurz in ein
zwei sätzen zu sagen was dieses
leitkonzept oder die idee dahinter
gewesen ist und anfangen möchte ich mit
der tate modern in london um bau eines
kraftwerks wir sehen hier das bild was
war die idee dahinter
es wäre verständlich wenn man alle
anderen zu sehen würde die die
architekten sie mit uns in konkurrenz
waren abgegeben haben wir haben am
meisten dass die kraft des bestehenden
riesenbau von oben ist es eigentlich
ungünstig weil als mensch bis sie auf
den boden und nimmt es doch von unten
her war das ist ein monstrum
ein riesen ding aus backstein und wir
wollten diese unglaubliche mächtigkeit
dieses industrie erhalten und nur so
manipulieren dass es eben von einem
kraftwerk zu einem museum werden konnte
das ist das erste projekt das wir machen
durften dass dann diese unheimliche
öffentlichkeit unheimlich weil london
ist die stadt weltweit welche am meisten
touristen für so die aktion gebäuden an
sie das hat jedes jahr fünf bis sechs
millionen besucher das ist eine
unvorstellbare zahl verglichen mit
anderen museen das heißt diese x
mächtigkeit die wir intuitiv erhalten
wollten ist nur deshalb gut weil so
viele menschen hat
wenn das in der schweiz stehen würde
wäre das fast schon beängstigend weil es
wäre zu mächtig hier stimmt das und das
war die richtige entscheidung auch diese
turban haldimann hier die turbinenhalle
die sehen ja in diesem in dieser
dimension dass der architekt der das
plante vor 70 80 jahren der volt addiert
die kathedrale des zentralen chef einer
kathedrale im blick gehabt also diesen
raum gestellt und wir haben diesen
eindruck noch verstärken wollen
nein das war die konzeptionelle basis
wir gehen ein paar werk weiter und zwar
interessiert mich das noch zu einer aus
studium stadion in peking das vogelnest
würde es danach genannt
was zeichnet dieses bauwerk aus
ich finde den übernamen den nickname
chinesen lieben das übernahmen ich finde
es auch grundsätzlich interessant weil
es sie immer darauf übernahm
an dieser frage von vorhin anknüpft
psychologie und der erstellung eines
gebäudes oder was menschen das heimat
und finden weil sie das siegtor die
chinesen haben diesen namen bereits fest
gegeben und wir wollten etwas machen
dass diese verästelung der struktur
tatsächlich an eine art nest also 1 1 8
home für viele leute auch gegen aussen
ausdrückt also nicht die unterseite der
zuschauer rampen man sieht ja nicht
einmal was das ist eigentlich ein
stadion ist
wir wussten dass ein olympiastadion
eigentlich etwas dummes ist weil das nur
für zwei wochen
da steht und nachher meistens eine ruine
wird hier wussten wir dass diese
riesenstadt fähig sein würde das weiter
zu bespielen nicht als leichtathlet
stadion sondern macht öffentlicher park
jetzt ist es ein partner es hat jeden
tag etwa 10.000 zuschauer oder zu
besucher die das wirklich wie ein nest
bespielen das heißt es ist ein
öffentlicher raum
das ist auch eine politische ein
politisch wichtiges detail weil die
menschen diesen raum benutzen um
zusammenzukommen
was eigentlich ja nicht immer in allen
staaten gewünscht ist dass das eine
plattform wird für die menschen die
gehen einfach gern hin
und das war hier das eigentlich tragende
konzept diese art des öffentlichen
raumes das wohl einfach gerne hingehst
um dich zu treffen mit freunden oder
besuch interessant wir werden später
noch über diesen über die wichtigkeit
von öffentlichen räumen sprechen nach
für demokratische staaten zum schluss
würde mich interessieren hamburg eines
der teuersten gebäude der welt
elbphilharmonie im letzten jahr eröffnet
das war auch eine
schnelle entscheidungen hatten diesen
sockel der bestand ja schon und wir
wollten den erhalten und stärken indem
er etwas trägt in der der konzertsaal
obendrauf und nicht innen drin versenkt
wird sondern oben drauf steht und ein
gebäude das vor groß ist das aber
eigentlich aus dieser anderen
materialität in der einspielung vorhin
sagt sah man dass durch die bewegtheit
der glasoberfläche etwas glück und es
entsteht eben wiederum für thema der
wahrnehmung dass mit dem was oder dem
himmel verbunden ist und diesen kontrast
dieser zwei bauteile der sockel aus
backstein und diesem gläsernen aufbau
für die musik das hatten wir sehr früh
als konzept und die bewegtheit des
daches die man mit wellen die man aber
auch mit segelschiffen oder wie auch
immer das ist ja assoziativen ist so
eindeutig an etwas gebunden jetzt diese
drei gebäude zeigen wie vielfältig ihre
architektur ist gibt es denn so etwas
wie eine handschrift von herzog
dämmerung
man kann sicher themen erkennen aber wir
wollten dem eigentlich immer ausweichen
dass man sagt ihr habt den unter den
stil weil er will sich eigentlich schon
festlegen in denen oder dem aber sag ich
mal in dem dem fach zu haben sie zu sein
oder nur jetzt gern mit holz oder mit
rechteckigen form zu wahren ich glaube
wir sind und haben das zunächst intuitiv
gemacht wir sind nicht mehr in einer
zeit wo du dich mit der stil definieren
solltest weil es so viele möglichkeiten
gibt und geradeaus sektor eigentlich
seitdem seite moderne auf der suche ist
danach wieder eine art standardisierung
zu kriegen etwas wo menschen sagen
jahren aussieht so also der fabrik sieht
so als elektrische sieht so aus die
moderne war der letzte versuch das so zu
etablieren der pc ist an der ou die
wussten alle wie man es machen und das
wissen wir nicht
wir wissen aber trotzdem es gibt ja den
ausspruch dass französischen health
claims buchung der gesagt hat ist der
stil das ist der mensch in jedem werk
kommt auch die person zum ausdruck
spiegelt sich die person dahinter ja das
heißt in ihren gebäuden sind irgendwie
auch sie selbst spür und sichtbar
ja wahrscheinlich könnte man da schon
dinge finden die mit unserer art wie wir
die welt anschauen zu tun hat das ist
unvermeidlich werden du hast hat sich
als architekt entscheide fällst dies
sind aber immer am zu tun mit dem ort
und mit der bauherrschaft das macht die
architektur auch anders als bildende
kunst aber trotzdem die art und weise
wie sie die welt sehen haben sie gesagt
kommt auch zum 1 was würde das heißen
kann könnte man das sehen das kann ich
nicht so allgemein zaandam ist sondern
jedes gebäude anschauen wenn wir finden
dass eben zum beispiel dieses gebäude
von der tat was sie ergänzen dieses
riesige backsteingebäude wenn man diesen
ort so hält zunächst und nur wenig daran
ändern
wir haben das mal mit tai chi verglichen
oder dass du die energie vom gegner von
dem was da ist nutzt als seine eigene
energie da kann man sagen ja ist das
vielleicht eine lebensphilosophie das so
weit würde ich nicht gehen ob ich sage
dass sie zumindest etwas das uns als
strategie interessiert als eine mögliche
art heute sich auszudrücken
und so könnte man vielleicht bei anderen
gebäuden auch dinge finden aber ich
möchte nichts uns selbst interpretieren
dass werden
kritiker haben das schon häufig versucht
zu sagen ja die sind so das sind jetzt
schweiz sondern erkennt dass daran oder
daran
daher bin ich immer ein bisschen
vorsichtig aber ich denke wenn man genau
hinschaut wie bei allen wenn man etwas
genau und sorgfältig anschaut
erkennst du immer mehr als das was man
so schnell sagt oder was man so schnell
sieht ich finde das ganz entscheidend
für unsere art zu denken dass genau
schauen was ist da was will die
bauherrschaft was ist das potenzial das
ist vielleicht das wort was ist das
wirkliche potenzial bevor du darum
bastelt dann kommt mit einem eigenen
stil
eigentlich ist ein stil etwas
christliches weil der stil zerstört das
potenzial bei der stil ist etwas das
wären acht krücke ist für jemand der
sich nicht frei aussetzen möchte der
gefahr des potenzials der ihr waren der
eigentlich offenen möglichkeiten du hast
immer so viele möglichkeiten offen
und dann stehen würden sie sagen ist ein
schema dass man sich hält dann etwas
äußeres das nicht an ihnen kommt auch
nicht vom ort kommt da könnte man gleich
gut iks beispiele erwähnen wo das so ist
das sehr viele architekten haben ja ein
steht
mich interessiert noch dieser
schaffensprozess selbst es gibt von dem
österreichischen philosophen ludwig
wittgenstein der selbst auch im haus
gewandt hat entworfen hat einen schönen
satz gesagt die arbeit an der
philosophie ebenso wie die arbeit an der
architektur ist oft auch eine arbeit an
sich selbst
das ist das kann ich unterstützen das
ist eben nur zuerst eine arbeit an sich
selbst indem du auch versuchst nicht auf
diese unmittelbaren empfindung die
meistens nur das wiederholen was du
schon weist den quasi zum opfer zu
fallen
ich finde es wichtig immer wieder eine
distanz zu haben zu den dingen
und das intuitiv ist wichtig trotzdem
aber es ist wichtig dass man das immer
auch wieder infrage gestellt deshalb
dieses dialogische arbeiten das sich
seit der schulzeit mit pierre dämmerung
habe ist das machst du ja zunächst das
kind nur intuitiv aber dann wird das zu
einem prinzip das in deinem leben
wichtig wird und das verweist sicher bis
zu einem gewissen grade auf deine person
dem kannst du gar nicht ausweichen
ob du schreibst oder mails oder post
oder interviews genau sie haben jetzt
wärmer spiro erwähnt sie sind seit der
kindheit befreundet haben zusammen
studiert und diese biologische prozess
ist ganz wichtig sagen sie aber diesen
dialog pflegen sie auch nach außen
nämlich mit diversen künstlern ebay zum
beispiel mit boys hatten sie kontakt usw
rémy zaugg der schweizer was kann ein
architektur von kunst lernen statt kann
von ganz vielen sachen lernen auch von
medizin und von psychologie und
philosophie und ist ja alles
interessanter sektor war ja für uns ein
studium das wir machten weil wir genau
so dachten über sektor ganz naiv das ist
etwas wo sachen zusammenlaufen
da kannst du deine sprachliche kompetenz
oder das zeichnen oder raus basteln und
experimentieren und das stimmte ja und
so mir das dann auch gelebt und ich
selbst habe ja auch mich lange jahre als
künstler gesehen bevor ich architektur
machte und dachte ich kann das parallel
entwickeln bis ich merkte dass ich dazu
nicht nicht fähig bin aber nicht die
gleiche qualität darin entwickeln könnte
und das ist auch nicht geht du kannst
zwei sachen nachdem der bin ich
überzeugt unsere zeit erlaubt das nicht
architektur ist ja wie alle anderen
berufen kreativ und der hof das ist ganz
wichtig dass du deine kreative kritische
wahrnehmen der intelligenz einsetzt in
dem gebiet und architektur hat einen
eher zu bildenden kunst ist keine frage
ist aber auch wieder sehr anders weil
eben architektur machst du für jemand
hat eine funktion groß dass keine
funktion kunst ist ungültig und diese
unnötige seite der kunst ist ist das
paradox ist dass auch faszinierende oder
kunst und architektur hat auch unnötige
seiten aber wenn es nicht die
notwendigkeit auch ausdrückt da zu sein
dann ist sie zugleich wertlos das da
unnötig oder sag ich mal der der teil
der den man nicht so leicht erklären
kann was ich tue weshalb einem etwas
gefällt oder weshalb du dich jetzt war
wohl fühlst
das ist vielleicht das künstliche oder
der kunst nahe teil von architektur
aber wenn wir mit künstlern arbeiten ist
nicht die idee dass jetzt kommt kunst
hinein sondern das interessante bei
künstler und ebay oder rémy zaugg ein
großartiger künstler und unglaublich und
intelligenter mensch ist die lust mit
anderen interessanten menschen etwas zu
machen und irgendwo hinzugehen wo du gar
nicht genau weiß wo das enden und das
war immer das interessante also nicht in
dem sinn der hals haben künstler und der
mal die wanderung und oder blau macht
eine figur die grimasse sondern diese
andere perspektive und anderen blick auf
die welt
wir haben wir haben mit welcher reisen
durch ganz china gemacht und an so viele
projekte initiiert und gemacht die nie
gebaut wurden und die aber angedacht
sind und das war das spannende das ihrem
prozess mitgemacht hat das ist
eigentlich nur eine es ein kleiner teil
der eigenen
die auseinandersetzung das ist etwas was
wir tatsächlich waren wir sehr verwöhnt
wir haben mit vielen tollen menschen
sachen entwickeln können
genau und wenn es um kunst geht also
kunst in der geschichte haben für viele
philosophen kunsttheoretiker armen
anspruch auf erkenntnis kunst ist
erkenntnis und sie sagen dass auch von
architektur das hat mich überrascht wie
meinen sie das ist ein vehikel wenn du
an der an etwas arbeitet dass wir ein
vehikel du musst das irgendwie machen
wenn du da reingezogen bist mit
eintragen oder mit einem team mit einem
büro das wir haben und gleichzeitig
benutzt du das wie gefäß oder und
gefährt die gestamp ein ort in und das
zwingt dich ja auch diesen ort
wahrzunehmen und dann selbst ein prozess
zu initiieren der dich an einem etwas
hin bringt hoffentlich wo du auch wieder
etwas text oder etwas lernt heute morgen
zum beispiel hatte mir so einen moment
diese nicht jeden tag oder aber wir
hatten einen moment wo wir haben einen
interessanten projekt in einem weingut
in satte million solchen schritt machte
wurde
jetzt geht es da wieder ein stück weiter
so und das ist etwas hatte das forschen
das hat etwas das in forschung oder dann
wahrscheinlich auch die arbeit eines
künstlers dann nicht unendlich ist
mich interessiert noch an architektur
für die menschen die mit ihr erleben und
die in ihrem leben eine ethische
erzieherische funktion haben was der
kunst ja auch zugesprochen wurde kann
sie uns zum besseren menschen machen
er hat das was finde ich
übersteigerte erwartung nicht denke es
ist einfach schön sein und gut
funktionieren und den menschen gefallen
vereinfacht ausgedrückt und dass sie gut
ist das heißt dass andere schlecht ist
das gute ist dass sie den ethisch dass
sie moralisch gut ist dass das ist
eigentlich unwesentlich schlecht ist ich
kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen
ich weiß nur dass die tour schon benutzt
wurde aus politischen gründen als
propaganda oder als versucht den
menschen den menschen irgendwo zu
beeinflussen aber diese das finde ich
dann nicht gut oder ist er wählte die
stalinistische architektur ich hoffe
hätte auch die faschistische aspekte
unter hitler diese gebäude die jetzt zum
teil noch rum stehen aber das
interessante ist wenn man zum beispiel
das haus der kunst in münchen sieht das
ist ja ganz klar eine nazi architektur
nach dem krieg wurde das wie das museum
verwendet heute ist das eine sogar
baumgart plattform für ein theaterstück
tun und deshalb funktioniert das du hast
so wie in scharen zu rein gehst und
dieser nazi zeit dass irgendwo im
hintergrund aber es hat einfach gute
räume da drinnen das heißt auch wenn du
architektur ideologisiert und in dem
sinn missbraucht und den menschen
versuchst unethisch oder unmoralisch
oder mit politisch unedlen zielen
den menschen nämlich vor der macht des
staates oder dieser ideologie der nazis
oder der des stalinismus zu beeinflussen
zur schicht wahrheit so ist und gleich
zu machen
dann verliert sich dieser spuk trotzdem
eher gelingt gar nicht gab ich aber sie
hatten mit dem birds nest und auch mit
der tat hatten sie diesen dieser
öffentlichen räume ja angesprochen die
die wichtig sind ja für unsere
demokratischen kulturen wichtig sind
oder der begegnung des austausches
darauf spiele ich eigentlich auch welche
rolle spielt denn architektur immer im
städtebau für für eine lebendige offene
stadt für eine gesellschaft die
irgendwie zusammen kommt und ich denke
das denken des öffentlichen raumes bei
einer großen architektur die wie eben
nicht privatisiert ist und nehmen zum
beispiel in olympiastadion einem museum
oder eine eine kirche sowieso dieser ob
das so zu denken dass der mensch sich
darin wohlfühlt und das animiert wird
sich zu treffen auch wenn wir das nicht
mal geplant hat diese informelle
aufenthaltsqualität die die tate modern
aus der turbinenhalle ist vielleicht
eines unsere gelungensten beispiele für
diese für diese absicht und auch dass
bereits nest gleichermaßen
da geht leute hin und hängen einfach
herum die treffen sich nicht weiß jetzt
ins olympiastadion gehen wollen oder
weil sie ins museum gehen wir uns und
sie es ist eine plattform also ein
banner ort wo du einfach gerne bist und
das ist seine art mehrwert istanbul das
wort aber es ist etwas das natürlich der
bau haben möchte dass die menschen gerne
hingehen aber es ist schwierig zu
formulieren mache mal einen raum an dem
die menschen dann gerne sind ich
erinnere zum beispiel viele kennen die
new york public library muss diese große
freitreppe davor hat das ist zwar seine
klassische buchform große treppe hinauf
geht es zum zum tempel artigen eingang
aber die treppe ist so gelegen dass die
menschen gerne drauf sitzen
ist eigentlich ein interessantes detail
obwohl es klassisch gedacht war
da gehst du rein gehabt würde bereitet
die weit bereitest dich vor für den
besuch der bibliothek aber die treppe
ist eben mehr die treppe wird von den
menschen das sind die menschen gleich
wie ameisen du gehst einfach hin und der
weg der weg der anderen macht das und
der aufenthalte anderen macht das dann
zu einer öffentlich interessanten
plattform
am schluss ist der mensch werde ich auch
die architektur macht und der mensch
welche die den raum bespielt das sieht
man auch bei fußballstadien die
funktionieren das sind plötzlich die
menschen im stadion drin viel wichtiger
als der sektor weil die den raum füllen
und den raum aber auf eine art füllen
dass der sektor quasi in den hintergrund
gerät sogar hässlich architektur kann
das leisten haben sie sagen diese
öffentlichen räume die ganz wichtig sind
die fehlern in der schweiz
warum ist das so und was macht man
dagegen dass sie fehle nicht aber die
schweizer tun nicht im gleichen maße wie
ausländische metropolen diese großen
architektur diese großen öffentlichen
gebäude diese großen stadien in der
schweiz die schweiz ist fragmentiert in
der schweiz ist dass der demokratische
städtebau leisten kann wahrscheinlich in
einer guten art vertreten
aber es ist eben immer sehr stark
geprägt durch die demokratische
fragmentierte macht welche nicht so
einfach
die nicht einfach so weg gewischt werden
kann zugunsten der großen geste
zugunsten der großen achse oder des
übermäßig großzügigen zugangs wie eben
diese freitreppen diese acht von orte
gibt es in der schweiz selten
das hat damit zu tun und werde jetzt den
politischen unter welchen politischen
bedingungen entsteht das siegtor das ist
ein ganz entscheidender aspekt dass sie
tun
sie haben ja 2005 ein buch publiziert
die schweiz ein städtebauliches partei
positiv schweiz in verschiedene mit
anderen autoren in verschiedene zonen
einteilen in metropolitanregion
städtisches leben in basel zürich genf
dann erst ländliche gegnern und und auch
so diese alpinen brachen wie sie das und
der die hoffnung war eigentlich man
sollte die verdichteten regionen noch
mehr verdichten und die anderen
sozusagen ausdünnen damit die natur
wieder zum vorschein kommt wurde das von
der politik mit offenen ohren empfangen
was wurde da davon umgesetzt
ich denke das bundesamt für raumplanung
hat in ihrem in seinen richtlinien und
seinen strategien ganz ähnliche maximen
und ganz folgt ganz ähnlichen
richtlinien
ich glaube die schweiz bildet sich immer
mehr nach diesem muster so ungefähr ab
wir haben ja das auch nicht erfunden
gesagt jetzt müsst ihr so machen das
würde gar nicht funktionieren in der
schweiz sondern wir haben ja auch die
schweiz beobachtet und die trends und
tendenzen versucht zu formulieren und zu
verstärken
das ist auch wieder eine nacht sanfte
methode dass du aufgrund der beobachtung
was da ist versucht zu sagen das kann
erreicht werden wenn du jetzt sagst wir
wollen alle städte so lassen wie sie
sind und man mitten im mittelland eine
ganz neue die metropole der schweiz
das ist unmöglich das kann doch nicht
machen das heißt nicht dass es nicht
besser wäre nur ein und zentralen
flugplatz alle haben ganz nahe zu diesem
flug die leute müssen das annehmen dass
dies gar nicht möglich
ich sage das nur das beispiel und die
diese metropolie sierung der städte das
findet statt und es sind vor allem diese
drei welten städte die metropolitane
funktionieren
aufgrund der werte der computrace als
der pendler und der der internationalen
wirtschaft
diese global headquarters diese die ist
vor allem in diesen drei städten geht
die wirtschaft konzentriert sich auch
wesentlich der auch bären ist er
verwaltungsstadt bundesstaat
ich glaube das passiert es ist uns ganz
wichtig dass man eben nicht nur ein
zentrum meistens ist zürich an das
zentrum das erwähnt wird dass das
beibehalten wird diese verschiedenen
pole das ist die stärke der schweiz und
die soll man behalten es soll eben
autobahn zug s bahn sollen an
verschiedenen kreuzungspunkten ausgebaut
werden und das pendeln so sehr dass auch
immer wieder kritisiert wird oder dass
der pendlerverkehr zunimmt ist auch
interessant weil der schweiz es ist so
nah von einer stadt zur anderen das ist
ja wie eine stadt die schweiz entwickelt
sich oder bewegt sich hin zu einem
urbanen netzwerk mit einer landschaft
dazwischen die hoffentlich eben auch
noch aus landschaft überhaupt
wahrgenommen wird und deshalb ist es
notwendig diese zersiedelung möglichst
einzudämmen weil sonst verliert die
schweiz einen wesentlichen faktor der
qualität der wohnqualität der
lebensqualität in dieser wunderbaren
landschaft dann haben die leute ein
einfamilienhaus auf dem land aber das
ganze ist ein siedlungsbrei ganz
versiegelt
sie planen und bauen ja nicht nur in der
schweiz sondern auf der ganzen welt wie
wir gesehen haben da würde mich
interessieren das braucht ja auch
sozusagen die kunst sich in andere
kulturen in andere mentalitäten
hineinzudenken stoßen klar abgrenzen
wir stoßen ich mache grenzen
das als ganz klar aber ich denke auch
wieder das führt auf die schweiz zurück
wir sind ein kleines land fast alle
schweizer sprechen zwei oder gar drei
sprachen und ich glaub ich denke wir
sind dafür nicht schlecht aufgestellt in
einer globalen welt
eben weil wir so einen kleinen heimmarkt
an uns nach draußen zu orientieren schon
früh wir wollen in basel an der grenze
und die metropolitane raum greift nach
frankreich nach deutschland über die
trams fahren ja nach deutschland nach
frankreich
aber grundsätzlich jeder schweizer ist
nahe beim ausland und ist es gewohnt mit
dem ausland und mit der sprache die sich
eben in frankreich oder in deutschland
oder in england sich früher sondern dazu
setzen wir werden auch so erzogen und
das ist ein vorteil wenn es darum geht
eben in anderen kulturen zu bauen weil
du musst dich auch anpassen ein
deutscher hat eine viel größere
nationale identität spürt er sich als
wir als schweiz oder der franzose
besonders mit diesen absolutistischen
monarchie und geschichte
das hat seine vorteile weil eben gewisse
dinge viel direktor zentral befohlen
werden und ausgeführt werden können aber
eigentlich ist das altmodisch an sie
würden sagen die schweizer tragen die
vielfalt schon in sich ja douglas ist
stolz sein schweizer zu sein aber du
hast nicht diese nationale identität die
ständig dich quasi begrenzt es ist heute
noch so dass viele deutsche vor allem
deutsch sprechen sowieso die franzosen
aber auch die spanier und wir sehen das
gerade in der struktur welche ein
globalisiertes business geworden ist
dass wir als schweiz vor da eine auch
ein vorteil haben wir wollen nach immer
ins ausland
deshalb bitte ich gesagt gern zu hause
und wollen immer wir wollten sehr gerne
und früh in frankreich barren in
deutschland da natürlich england amerika
asien und ich denke es hat damit zu tun
schweizer zu sein hilft diese innere
offenheit oder vielfalt
für die kreativität sie sagen kreativ
kreativität ist das wichtigste prinzip
des lebens ja das denke ich wirklich ich
denke kreativität ist aber nicht an
künstler geborenen architekten ich denke
es ist wichtig dass sie kreativ sind in
dem ziemlich interessante fragen mehr
interessante fragen stellen und auch
nachhaken und etwas herausholen in jedem
beruf müsstest du möglichst an orten
gehen wo du noch nicht warst und das
kannst du alles machen jeder beruf hat
ein kreatives potenzial und ich denke
das ist ganz wichtig hat wieder mit
diesem schönheits thema zu tun etwas zu
machen das dich als person als mensch
ins zentrum die dann nach arbeit stellt
du musst das wollen auch wenn du
angestellt ist
natürlich habe ich einen vorteil ich bin
architekt ich bin verwöhnt ich kann
überall hingehen aber ich denke du
kannst auch als angestellter sogar
jemand der die straße wischt das ist
vielleicht jetzt schon ein bisschen ein
preußisches thema das kreativ noch das
schön machen das häufchen dass du da weg
wie es mit den blättern dieses geräusch
des blätter dass der blätter ich sage
das nicht zu ihnen ich möchte nicht
falsch verstanden werden aber ich denke
es gibt in jedem in jeder handlung eine
schönheit und eine kreativität und das
ist das was der mensch jeder mensch
erleben können das ist da drin aber
jetzt beim angestellt sein fand es
interessant zu lesen dass sie sagen sie
haben kein talent dazu
sie waren wagen gestellt sie war nach
einer assistenz aber das passt nicht
wenn sie können das nicht
ja das ist eine limitierung und mir ist
es jetzt gelungen dank piano und dank an
den menschen die auch in ihren talenten
meine talente ergänzen und ausweiten und
uns ermöglichen eben an einem anderen
ort hinzugehen wo ich nicht angestellt
sind aber trotzdem sind sie immer
gebunden durch den bauherren mit räumen
sie machen wir da von der eigenen bank
zu sein
nein ich denke dass auch so ein klischee
der architekt der keine
freiheit hat oder wir sind vom budget
eingeschränkt oder wir sind jetzt da
gezogen dass das baugesetz und darf
nicht so hoch
zum glück gibt's das schon die
architekten weil die architekten könnten
gar nicht auf einer weißen leinwand
quasi am toaster blue das ideale haus
das gibt es gar nicht
das ist genau der unterschied zur kunst
der künstler
er findet seine eigene sprache sein
eigenes bild das niemand sagt die masse
machen oder was sie machen muss kunst
ist unnötig aber gerade deshalb so
wichtig für uns und der architekt hat
doch eine gewisse funktionalität und
nutzen das erreichen muss und wenn er
das nicht erreicht dann ist alles andere
auch völlig überflüssigen und die
kreativität sieht man an ihren gebäuden
finde ich immer an diesem
unkonventionellen immer gegen den
mainstream gegen das was irgendwie state
of the art ist machen sie was neues was
stört sie am konventionellen und am
mainstream das ist vielleicht das
psychologische dass sie suchten das es
ja manchmal schwierig ist in einem feld
zu arbeiten am gebiet wo du merkst dass
eigentlich alle
nach diesen gesetzen funktionieren und
dann am schluss sind die häuser so aus
und sowas und so als das ist vielleicht
schon eher hat flucht davor aber weil
wir eben nicht so klare regeln haben
dass sie zu wir haben nicht mehr wie im
19 jahrhundert oder noch früher umso
mehr quasi den zwang es gibt jetzt diese
gotische tendenz des schwitzens dieser
der auflösung der wand in klare
filigrane erste und dazwischen hat dass
diese gläsern
membranen oder in der romanik diese
diese schwere wir haben das nicht und ob
es vielleicht gibt es einen anderen 2 ja
ich kenne ich immer etwas neues zu
machen
das ist aber nicht ein zwangs und ich
denke du musst eine lösung finden die
für einen ort stimmt und für eine
bauherrschaft stimmt und da kann es gar
keine routine geben es ist gar nicht
möglich
es ist nicht möglich zu sagen heute ein
schulhaus oder eine universität muss so
ausschauen wenn du einen konkreten ort
baust neben der eth zürich am alten ort
oder der universität damit diesen
historischen gebäuden alles ist alles
ein bisschen anders in ihrem maßstab was
willst du da für eine standardisierte
lösung haben das heißt du bist
eigentlich eh gezwungen ganz spezifische
orte zu schaffen
und deshalb ist es nicht ein zwang es
wäre falsch und ich denke da kommt etwas
anders ins spiel wenn du auf deine
arbeit zu rückstaus was architekt du
hast ja dann 15 20 jetzt mittlerweile
als 40 jahre distanz und du gehst ihn
dann siehst du dieses gebäude echt ist
oder ob du quasi betrogen hast ob du
links und rechts gespielt hast da was
abgeschaut da was weil das hält sich
nicht in der zeit nur was volle
überzeugung dahinter war eine
authentische und für diesen ort gemachte
lösung zu finden nur das wieder steht
quasi das ist doch dieser diesem dieser
erosion welche die zeit ziemlich
springen könnte wo haben sie betrogen
haben wir haben
ich weiß dass mit dem betrügen nur
deshalb weil weil es mir auffällt bei
gebäuden und wir haben sehr früh
angefangen nicht zu betrügen nicht als
moralische kategorien deshalb war ich
vorhin auch so klar als sie über die
sowjetische sondern als weil ich
überleben möchte dass architekt mit mein
business mit meinem mann meiner arbeit
und weil es dich zwingt zu einer art
ehrlichkeit und offenheit es zwingt sich
radikal offen zu sein gegenüber dem was
du eigentlich machst bin ich wirklich
stimmt das sind das meine gedanken oder
sind das unsere gedanken für diesen ort
sind die zwingend aus diesem dialog
hervorgegangen oder sind dann noch so
ist dann noch so etwas dabei
das da auf den büchern herumliegt oder
das von links und rechts kommt ich habe
mich deshalb auch sehr früh von
architektur publikationen abgewandt mich
interessiert es nicht was andere
architekten machen überhaupt nicht da
sage ich aber nicht aus arroganz sondern
auch selbstschutz
ich möchte völlig selbst bestimmen
können mit pierre mit unseren partnern
wie wäre ein thema angehen und was wir
jetzt da aber sie sagen zusammenstellen
aber das gebäude keine noch so echt und
authentisch sein und und originell wenn
es die bevölkerung nicht annimmt haben
sie den job schlecht gemacht ja klar das
ist aber wieder ein anderes thema das
habe ich auch vor den versuchen es okay
und das ist im vordergrund und wenn du
das verfolgt wenn du eben gebäude machst
das für die menschen und diesen ort ist
mit dieser funktion eines museums oder
eines fussball stadions oder eines
restaurants dann ist das zb ein
wichtiger ausgangspunkt für diese
authentizität ich vorhin erwähnte das
ist dann etwas ganz entscheidendes das
ist eben
für diese bestimmung stimmung gemacht
ist das ist viel wichtiger als wenn du
eine formale obsession hast oder ein
stilistisches element dass ich irgendwie
nach plagt werden ich möchte nicht
geplagt werden von meiner sektoren ich
denke nie nachts an meiner sie tun das
mich verfolgt wer gespenst und das würde
es tun wenn es nicht aus unserer eigenen
überlegungen aus unseren eigenen
konzeptuellen überlegungen
hervorgegangen wäre dass das ein sehr
guter selbstschutz ein sehr guter test
für architektur würde ich jedem
architekten empfehlen das zu befolgen
eine generelle schwierigkeit ist mit
architektur dass man für die zukunft
baut diese gebäude bleiben lange
bestehen aber die zukunft ist ungewiss
das hat sich so an sich und sie
verändert sich rasant
stichwort digitalisierung und so weiter
vielleicht ganz zum schluss noch eine
bemerkung dazu wie sie damit umgehen mit
dieser schwierigkeit für eine zeit zu
bauen die sie nicht kennen
das ist nicht das problem das problem
ist dass dafür jetzt bauen muss und das
muss jetzt stimmen und wenn es jetzt
stimmt dann hat es auch später eine
qualität wenn die wenn es so die
menschen jetzt stimmt aber die die
digitalisierung ist tatsächlich eine
neue kraft in unserer gesellschaft in
unserer kultur welche die architektur in
frage stellt oder starke frage stellen
könnte
wenn künstliche intelligenz cyborg all
diese möglichkeiten möglichen szenarien
also ja nicht jetzt spekulieren aber
insofern könnte man etwas festhalten
wenn diese künstliche intelligenz und
wenn diese dieser hybrid situation
mensch-maschine wenn sich das entwickelt
wenn das zu einer neuen realität wird
dann stehen wir in einer dann entstehen
gesehen
schafften oder kulturen die wir uns
überhaupt nicht vorstellen können das
ist völlig unmöglich
aber ich sagte das ist für architektur
schwierig besonders schwierig vorstufe
tastatur ist arabisch und ist etwas
ganzheitliches das ist wiederum nicht
ein moralischer begriff ganzheitlichen
rechtlichen direkten sind für den
menschen
du bist mit allen sinnen teilt ist
richtig nur dann diese stein an der welt
du berührst du siehst du riechst sie
sogar du hörst sie ist und ganz anders
in einem stein raum zu sein was ihnen
eher drama drinnen hölzernen gebäude und
diese sinnlichkeit ist das was uns
menschen definiert ist das was uns
menschen sagt ich bin jetzt gerne dieser
architektur oder ich bin in jedem sektor
wenn du dich verabschiedet ist im
virtuellen welten und da gibt es ja
bereits auch tendenzen es gibt diese
diese auch in lucio ist illusion räume
wir sind auch in einem solchen
inklusions ein fernsehstudio diese
ganzen kardashian world und all diese
virtuellen realität wenn die überhand
nehmen weil der mensch anders ist leider
nicht mehr auf diesen gleichen
prinzipien funktioniert werden nicht
mehr im gleichen maße gerne die frische
luft hat oder das riecht wenn du auf dem
auf einem berg steigst all diese sachen
die uns wichtig sind die sind
fundamental wichtig für unsere
konzeption von architektur
das wird es auch radikal verändern denn
das verändert dann ist die architektur
obsolet so wie wir sie jetzt kennen
herr herzog vielen herzlichen dank für
dieses gespräch
danke
ja nächste woche spricht barbara bleisch
mit weltbekannten psychologen steven
pinker der nichts weniger verlangt als
eine neue aufklärung und jetzt gleich
zeigt die stern schon eine kunst einen
eindrücklichen film über den schweizer
fotografen daniel schwarz anlässlich der
aktuellen ausstellung im bündner
kunstmuseum in chur
bleiben sie also dran und einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]